What do you think is next?
Like if you at the cellphone and you look at technology
and the integration in our lives.
What do you think is the next step?
I dont think people understand.
People don't understand
I don't think people actually understand what the f*ck is actually coming.
Every single person here besides the health and well
being of their family and money... values time.
As we become more busy... we start valuing
time tremendously.
When you're looking at video it is taking up your time.
Audio is incredibly passive.
Passive.
though for everybody kind of passively consumes.
pay triple attention.
Listening to something in the first five minutes
when you wake up and getting out of bed
and getting ready .
Is information that you're consuming..
that you're not looking at your phone because you're
in the shower.
Like imagine brushing your teeth in the morning.
Remembering that you need socks and saying
in your bathroom ...
Hey Google. Hey Apple. Hey Alexa. Hey Facebook
or whatever else comes out.
Because the next search engine is voice.
And Alexa's ahead.
Hey Alexa,  buy my soap.
Alexa, play my daily briefs.
Alexa, who's Kobe Bryant?
Alexa, play i'm still standing by Elton John.
Hey Alexa, when does England play in the world cup?
That exists... because I know that's the next
landscape of attention.
And I genuinely believe that voice as a platform
is going to be a much bigger deal in entertainment,
in utility, in commerce.
Instead of predicting... I just recognize
that voice is working.
That podcast consumption is on the rise... It's just being
first faster and making a bet in the early indicators
instead of guessing.
So it feels like i'm predicting the future
but i'm taking innovation that's happening around me
and i'm deploying it against my own reality at that time.
My bet was that we would pick convience over history.
Because I only care about one thing. One... One thing...
The end customer.
We will always pick convience over everything.
It's all about time saving. So Uber won
because it saved you time.
Prime wins because it saves you time.
Anything that saves us time right?
You guys want everything right now, always, fast,
right now, always. Anything that's slow? Sh*t!
Like, slow internet is like devestating.  Right!?
Like, speed... we become addicted to speed.
So I think voice is speed.
Even if you have your phone right here.
If you can say Alexa, or Google, or Apple..
What's my.. What is my schedule today?
And the house is talking to you.. it's just faster
then just taking your phone.. hitting.. turning on.
It's just friction and we hate friction.
Alexa and voice is the future of a frictionless world.
It is going to explode.
There are things that you're  doing now.
That will blow you away.
That you'll be doing only in voice. Like I genuinely
think i'm going to poke my head out of the shower
three times per shower saying tell Babin
to meet me on 19th street.
It's going to be unbelievable speed, utility
and I think for example texting will decline
because it's going to be faster to say it
and get that person to know the information
then it is to grab the phone and do it.
Because I know in 2026... right? In 8 years
when all of you realize how much better that is
then this.. It's going to matter.
Hey Alexa, buy this.
I mean that's it.
I just bought Doveman's soap.
Like what do people think is coming Pedro?
Call Aj Vaynerchuk
Calling Aj Vaynercock ( robot voice)
Siri calls our last name VaynerCOCK!! ( laughs)